we go ahead and get started thank you
all for coming as you know I can you
turn down the volume a little bit on
this so it doesn't echo as I always stay
to our conference is normally on
thursdays but when luminaries come to
visit we move it to different days of
the week so we have a luminary here
today and his doctor and Rico Carrera if
you've never met him you've probably
read his papers or heard of his papers
very well known in the field he also has
a recently published the third edition
of his textbook called guide to health
informatics and Rico is SEO tell when he
starts talking from Australia and he is
currently a director of the center for
health informatics at McCarrick naughty
Macquarie University in Sydney and he
received his medical degree from the
University of Sydney and PhD from
University of New South Wales so you're
what probably wondering why I put this
slide up here so about 11 years ago I
happened to be in Australia zexion
Melbourne but he kindly had me come down
to Sydney say I look a little younger
there but these but these are arguably
or maybe not arguably the the three most
prominent informatics researchers in
Australia Johanna Westbrook some of you
probably know of her work she's also I
don't know if anyone's here who's on our
health information exchange project but
she's on our technical expert panels and
she dials in at nine a.m. pacific time
which is something in the middle of the
night and firmer gravi who's also done
very interesting and important work in
the field then some other guy from ohsu
and then my my daughter the one who's
starting medical school this fall who I
took on that trip who was 13 at the time
and you can't really tell too well from
this picture but his office used to be
in this house that was
a half mile from the beach and we were
there in december you know which is like
late spring in australia and it was just
incredible but now he's moved on from
University of New South Wales and
doesn't have quite as nice of a venue
but he continues to do very impressive
work so i will switch over to him and
let him talk and and as with as with all
of our talks we are streaming live and
any people out in cyberspace want to ask
any questions just send it through
twitter to hashtag demise comp so and
rico thank you very much good morning
everybody and when i say good morning I
really mean it it's 2am for me so thank
you much to join a bill for bringing me
out and I'm looking forward to the
minooka conference it's going to be fun
so from one city of bridges to another
so I feel at home here in Portland we we
have sea water and under our bridges but
so what i thought i would do before i
started the talk proper i thought i
would sort of do a speed dating thing
and introduce you to who we are in our
group and give you a sense of the work
we do so if the substance of today's
talk is not right in your area but you
hear about something that you're
interested in then maybe we can chat
afterwards in another some time set
aside there's afternoon to or send me an
email so okay so we all live under the
umbrella of this Australian Institute of
Health innovation which is a hundred
research scientists totally committed to
research health services and probably
seventy percent informatics eHealth so a
very very large group and we've been
running really as individuals from
nearly fifteen twenty years now so it's
been around for a long time Bill's
mentioned already Joe Westbrook so we
have three large groups within Institute
so Joe's group is focused on the impact
of implementation of our health systems
workflow impacts in
options multitasking interested in H
care increasingly and a strong focus on
evaluation so really great work comes
out of Joe's group Jeffrey is the
non-implementation the token health
services researcher and his focuses
around system resilience implementation
effects organization culture etc and
he's got a couple of books out now on
health care resilience which with Eric
all nagel which just been published so I
directly to them and then this this lot
over here by the way i'm in my first
trip bill to the US when I was at HP
Labs and we met somebody the gates in my
god you've got an accent and yeah you
have men so so this is my group and my
groups focus I mean it's very hard when
you do informatics and do research to
say you have a single theme but our
focus probably is on supporting decision
making in one way or another and and the
focus is really because of all the
interventions you know telemedicine
records the one that has the biggest
impact on outcomes time and again and
study the decision support system so we
really know we get this right we're
going to make a difference but equally
know every every EHR has rules and
alerts in there we've built expert
systems for decades now so the
researcher gender has changed and what
is our focus you know so I call it next
generation decision-making research you
know there are new decision makers out
there is no longer the doctors it's the
nurses its consumers we're not longer an
uncle focusing on therapy decisions or
diagnosis we're using online systems for
cbt for a mental health etc so lots of
different different decision classes we
will get no longer just looking at the
HR / data sources wearables or granted
reality social media just so many
different things that we can feed into
the decision support systems a strong
focus also on personalization so not
just patients like me what should i do
but patients like mine if you're a
clinician what should I do with this
patient
compared to other people who have been
in a similar situation and as bill said
focus on safety which is another one
shared with researchers here so making
sure we do no harm with the IT so of the
first group this is the 1 i'll be
talking bit about later on today and
this group is focused really on on on
the notion that we can use sources like
the HR as as a new source of evidence
you know when we don't have our cts to
provide evidence then the best evidence
is the observational record over the
last hopefully 10 or 20 years and so
this group here is working with chris
Longhurst on the green button technology
which is really all about finding a
patient who's just been admitted for you
and saying look I'd I don't have any
rcts you've got naughty morbidity what
do I do for you or it might be a rare
disease let's find a match cohort from
that record that we know historically
that has been very similar to you based
on some similarity metric and let's
predict what what the most likely course
of therapy or treatment will be for you
and this is called green button
technology I don't know why it's called
green button technology anyway the other
thing that that the group is doing is
dynamic real-time forecasting so in the
same way you get a weather report
imagine you're admitted and the idea is
we don't just say your risk of death on
admission is you know point2 we say here
is the envelope for your length of stay
for your risk of infection for your risk
of death for your risk of readmission
and so people can look at that
probability shape over the next week and
say okay what should we do around care
they're so very interesting stuff and
happy to talk about that later on the
next group i think has strong resonance
with some folks here too which is we
have a strong interest in manipulating
the published literature so we call that
computable evidence lab and the idea
here is that the business of systematic
review is a broken business model in a
way that it's very hard to keep up with
literature let alone to synthesize it
and if you're in Cochran Cochran is way
behind its to-do list so we're very
interested in
we can bring informatics to the process
of supporting us reviews and ultimately
just having systematic reviews of the
click of a button now what's the
research say today for my patient which
sounds ambitious but when you break it
down systematic reviews have defined
steps you know starting from search
something that maybe build you know a
little bit about or all the way through
to extracting the data with text mining
tools doing the synthesis and then
generating reports and when you break it
down it turns out that we have a lot of
the technologies already in place our
challenges really are around extraction
of the right elements and it turns out
that that doing this that the meta
analysis itself is already a done deal
and regenerating reports as just
template based so so really it's just
that extraction and a little bit of the
synthetic task that's missing another
big problem we have really is the
literature itself is in bad shape so a
lot of the research that's relevant you
know was published a long time ago we
didn't have as well structured RCT
reports for example so that's that's our
problem there which is dealing with the
legacy of poorly formatted previous
studies again happy to talk about it
later on if somebody's interested in
that area the next area also deals with
evidence and this is a co-authorship map
so these are co-authors of systematic
reviews for tamiflu and you can see that
the folks in blue or Co publish and the
systemic reviews they publish tend to
suggest that Tamiflu is of not great
value should really worry about it
doesn't make a difference the guys in
orange tend to be very positive you know
you've got to use it you've got a stock
pilot nationally blah blah blah and you
can see that there's very little
relationship between the blues and the
oranges any guesses about what the
colors mean any guesses of what the
labels might be folks on this side of
pro Tamiflu folks on that cider and
negative this is not a hard question mmm
correct this is a conflict of interest
map everybody in orange has been funded
in some way by the manufacturers of the
drug so we've known for a long time that
that that trial data is compromised or
biased this is evidence that systematic
review data is biased so this came out
in annals a couple of months ago if
you're interested and so this stream of
work really we call evidence
surveillance we're really looking at
evidence as published looking for it
early signals that there are biases or
in fact in the case of Tamiflu we're not
even making a judgment about whether the
evidence is good or bad but there's a
clear divergence between groups about
what's good or bad and so that's just a
signal that there's a problem in the
evidence base it doesn't say necessarily
that there's anything wrong and so this
is not sort of saying farmer is bad
farmer data is bad but there's an issue
we're also interested in how evidence is
processed by people once they read it
and so for example we were I know it's
very topical here in the US we're
looking at aunty anti-vaccine sediment
in Twitter streams and just trying to
see how amenable the anti-vaccine groups
are to two messages about vaccinations
and it's very interesting when you look
at that with the community structures
online they are very insular very very
self referential do not look at evidence
beyond other groups so at least the
social media analysts suggest that if
you want to target these folks then
they're not susceptible generic public
messaging at all I already have their
own communities and you're going to find
different ways in so very interesting
stuff and I think we have a paper in jmi
are coming out soon on that bill
mentioned farah McGraw be and ferry's
interest has been in safety of eHealth
she's been looking at at incident
reports safety turn reports rated to IT
harms and has looked at it I think
incidents from Australia also we managed
to get into the FDA and put a whole
bunch of stuff and two years ago the
English NHS gave us access to all of
their safety reports so we've just
published a paper in international
journal of medical thematics looking at
the safety reports in the NHS and the
big
feature there is large-scale failure so
in other words you know 20,000 patients
get the wrong letter so that it's very
interesting so far has beaver de way
over the years and developed a
classification of HIIT errors and a lot
of an associate technical not just
technical and in that classification I
mean I know there's a bold statement but
it's now used as the basis of lots of
lots of reports so Pennsylvania
Authority ACR is used it this is Wales
etc so it's not it's not complete there
are the views and how you would classify
it but it's if getting wide use so I
think it's a great contribution from
Farah in the last group is consumers as
decision makers and we've had a platform
called healthy me which we've had now
for about seven years which is for
researchers where you can take a toolbox
and provide different consumer
informatics interventions whether it's
to provide social networks for our
clinical evidence pathways guidelines
and over just has been whether or not
you actually can change outcomes there's
a lot of studies around adoption but
very little about impact and so we've
done a whole bunch of rcts and trials
and I just want to point out too that
our relevance one is on flu vaccination
where we managed to double vaccination
rates by giving people access to this
tool and we've had a very similar
finding in STI screening getting young
adults too to be screened again
providing this stuff so but it does show
strong evidence interestingly we've just
finished an RCT on adult asthma
populations with no impact whatsoever so
it's not that this is always going to
work and we try to understand what it is
about the nature of the task so with
adult asthmatics and getting them to be
on action plans for excess emotion and
these these screening things and our
guess is it has to do with having lived
with the disease for many many years you
already feel like you know what you're
doing even if you may not necessarily do
so okay that's the end of the speed
dating this is to remind you that there
for that what we do in Australia is very
similar to what you do but there are
little Australian tweaks to it that
that that so we're the same but
different we're also relaxed I noticed
this guy's got solar panels on his ears
i'm not sure what what that's all about
you can see why they could hurt you
can't you look at the muscles on this
guy is a strong fella okay to the talk
itself today and today's talk is one on
analytics but but it's not going to be a
technical talk i'm going to talk through
example so i'm going to give you two
case studies and really took a lot more
about approach to analytics and clinical
data because i think the challenges we
have are much less in terms that
equality or the tools but really in the
great challenge of looking at large
masses of data sensibly and meaningfully
so so the focus is on temporal patterns
of care and temporal patterns are
well-known to us in in healthcare at
patient level you know we use the the
time pattern in an EKG or the order of
symptom presentation to we just know
that these are very important signals
and we know that you know they're all
kinds of seasonality patterns that are
really important so so there's nothing
new and the idea that there's an
unfolding temporal pattern to data and
okay this is just annual death rates in
my country and so what's going on in
July shark attacks what's happening what
why we all what are we doing here are
these tourists drowning are you on the
same schedule that we're on no we're not
that's right that's the winter season
for us that sets the flu that that's
just yeah right so you're thinking july
summer holidays no it's just six months
out so it was a trick question Phil done
professor Hirsch and of course if you
look at that signal over time you see
it's it's regular but but different so
our just is not in those data but in
health service data process data the
sort of detritus of day-to-day life that
that you would generate as a clinician
as you go through your act of ordering
medication
or during lab tests looking at work
flows what are the signals and patterns
in the data of our practice that's our
interest and you know my sense is you
know we understand the physiology of the
human body really well you know that
there are styling laws about how the
heart works but we don't really have the
same laws yet around how our
organizations work they need to be basic
processes that that underpin them all
but we still sort of see health service
delivery not in the same way that we
would approach clinical data sets so why
bother well number one just knowing when
you need to allocate resources staff the
kinds of stuff is going to help you
deliver a better service but it's got a
big impact on patient called in safety
so you need to make sure that the
services you need are available when
they should be here you want to avoid
harms you want to make sure that
something is needed it's available so it
really is not a small problem especially
when you look at the at Regina causes of
harm what we're doing in health care
delivery it is something worthy of study
so the first case study and this is
probably a problem well known to you
isn't it which is the issue of tests or
to follow up just because a test is
ordered doesn't mean anybody ever reads
it that so that's that's understood i
think and and the data for out of out of
the states is between twenty to sixty
percent of inpatient tests are not
followed up i still find that figure
hard to digest i'm not quite sure i
believe it but but that's what
individual studies seem to show and it's
not just an economic disaster as it sits
there are important consequences you
know nearly half of your malpractice
suits with diagnosis come from failing
to follow up and a lot of those tests
are clinically significant those that
are looked not looked at carry data that
may have changed care so so our question
really was well what is underpinning
this ferry to follow up in hospital you
know other any laws that govern what's
happening here bad
Systems bad clinicians something else
what's going on so we were very lucky we
worked with one of our teaching
hospitals which allowed us to timestamp
everything from the moment an order is
generated or a lab is generated to the
moment somebody clicked on a view result
so we could see the whole process from
lab receiving it when the lab finishes
with it so we had all sorts of metrics
for time that we could look at and that
that really made the study possible and
you could just see here you know it's
mainly internal medicine surgery so what
did we find first the first results very
high level and the the faith that the
failure rate is around three-point-two
percent at discharge so not sixty
percent and I don't think we're any
different to the states I just think
once you measure it more accurately
you're going to get more realistic
figures and two months out it did sort
of heart this is the figure here that
was a bit disturbing so forty percent of
patients did had at least one test that
was not followed up and twenty percent
of those unreviewed tests were abnormal
so you know that that points to an issue
and at this point to be honest my team
probably wasted six months where we
looked at the data by you know by test
panel by physician by specialty by
whether it's normal or abnormal just to
look at associations and at some point
we really got stuck because that you
know you can imagine this is a very
large data set in some ways and there
was very little information there so at
this point you know I said guys we need
to stop we need to think you know we
need to think from first principles we
need to have some hypotheses about what
this data set is going to show if
there's some understanding of clinical
practice before we come and look at the
data and I'm not a great fan of just
looking through data sets for
statistical associations I think you
need to have something in your head so
so what's going on I mean at the top
level you've got to
to get oh sorry sly just explaining the
discrepancy between the first two
results back which ones just the the
three percent versus forty percent I
just didn't quite understand it so my
guess is that the forty percent results
are based on estimates and we were in
unusual circumstance or actually being
able to directly measure what people did
so so being able to to measure every
time somebody click the button and saw
the results so those earlier studies
were not based on be able to directly
measure what's going on it may be the
case that care is worse in the States
but I don't believe it you know and
there will be a shock to me if your
results are not similar when you use the
same measurement so you know if you use
different methodology you're going to
get a different number and my guess is
this is a more accurate number does that
help yeah so two big one it one is that
simply people are ordering tests that
are unnecessary and therefore that's
wasted money and they're not following
up because they didn't need them in the
first place and the second set of
hypotheses are they look these are
necessary tests but somehow they got
missed maybe the doc didn't know the
test had arrived maybe they were too
busy or understaffed or sometimes that
they actually did get the data but they
didn't get it through the way we
measured maybe they've got phoned up by
the labs and were given some information
and actually for urgent things like
potassium's that that was the workflow
in our lab but even that is sort of
complicated so the question really is
how do you look at data sets which are
not designed to test hypotheses you know
this is observational historical data
this is not an experiment and so our
approach to say look that there must be
temporal signatures which distinguish
one hypothesis from another so for
example let's say I'm ordering tests I
don't care about then as time goes on
I'm just not going to change my behavior
I'm always going to be ignoring those
tests if I really wanted those tests
then over time I'm going to start to get
so you can imagine that there will be
patent but I said let's start with the
most basic hypothesis we can think of
which is that this is just driven by
workflow this is just what happens as a
as a result of the way this system is
built this is the result you know you
know they are saying systems deliver the
result they were designed to do and so
my first presumption is that this
failure to follow up is a natural
property of the way we deliver care and
if that's the case then the most simple
temporal hypothesis is that follow-up
rates are dependent on how long a test
is available for review clearly if a
test has just been there for 10 minutes
it's Chancellor review is quite low it's
been 10 days someone's had a chance to
look at it so I said let's just line up
the data when was the test ordered when
was it red and what was the gap in time
and what does that graph look like and
this is what we got so not claiming
starling law but very interesting so
clearly any test that's been available
for a long time has a very high chance
of being reviewed these these are tests
that had a very limited chance to be
reviewed and and you can see that's
where the big failure to follow up
happens so they so what's going on so
these are day of discharge orders and
you can see nearly half of the tests
that were never seen were ordered on day
of discharge very interesting and when
you look at follow-up rates so you can
see a discharged a test has a twenty one
percent chance of being missed compared
to one point nine percent for other ones
so a huge difference so half of the
problem is a probably a workflow problem
to do with why is this test being
ordered on the day the patient is
leaving and that study came out archives
couple of years ago so you know that
that still needs to be tested further
but it changes the focus of your
thinking you say okay now so it's not
about bad docs it's not about processes
it's about how
how we coordinate discharge and how we
coordinate test ordering so you know
discharge planning should incorporate
plans around tests we we you know you
shouldn't be able to order a test that's
going to take 10 days to return when the
patient's got two days of inpatient time
left this is where you can connect
discharge planning to alerts you know
letting people know how long it will
take before is that comes back or saying
even at know it but the patient's going
home today and other part is is going
back to the consumer so the consumers
oops also need to know when they leave
hospital there are still pending tests
they need to be able to maybe talk to
their primary care physician and say
look I know that I had I had a chest
xray that on the day I left and we need
to follow that up the other thing is is
it's about the handoff that happens at
discharge once once the patient is
discharged people think well my job is
to get the discharge summary done wash
my hands but what this says no this says
look there are still tests coming
through the pipeline and we need to let
you know about that let and you may need
act upon those things so we're again we
looked with people about important
results that have become available a few
days later so that was really
interesting and to me the lesson there
were really was about not getting lost
on the data thinking about first
principles what might be happening in
the process and this this only explains
half of the problem there are the things
going on but that was I just thought a
very very interesting result so the
second case study is is weekend effect
which I'm sure you know about so this is
um you know that your risk of death is
higher if you're admitted on the weekend
which is which always is a disturbing
thing to say and there are really two
two explanations that people worry about
the first is selection bias in other
words the folks turning up in on the
weekend a sicker they're dying more
because there they've got greater acuity
or whatever and the second is that we're
not doing such a good job on the weekend
that we have lower staff rates
that we don't have the same staff on and
that somehow there might be higher rates
of the actor genic harm or or people
aren't getting what they need and one
interesting clue comes from some of the
studies which have happened in the past
we look at ed and intensive care and
they suggest that if you're running a
good 24-7 service then weekend effect
doesn't really seem to affect those
units so we set off again to look at
observational data to help us try and
and tease apart these two big causes
because up until this point no one's
really been able to answer which which
is it and this paper came out last year
and bmj quality and safety and so just
to give you a sense I don't if you can
read it but these are the past studies
that we had at the time which looked at
weekend effect and you can see the odds
ratios for death are all showing weekend
effect and a lot of the studies are
looking at patients with stroke Pease
you know rupt ruptured aneurysms etc
very few looking at the whole population
but all pointing to the fact that
there's something going on there are a
couple of studies that seemed to say
doesn't exist and that they're the ones
that you know make us wonder what is
going on so this was a much bigger study
we had access to our state's public
hospital system and you know most care
in in in Australia is in the through the
public system and so we had access to
about 3.3 million admissions 550 30,000
patients and we also linked it to the
death registry because we wanted to
capture deaths that happened post
discharge just because you've gone home
alive doesn't mean we've done a good job
so we wanted to make sure that one week
post discharge if you died we also
captured you and then what we did was we
just compared weekends to eat dates and
try to see if there was any excess
mortality was one different to the other
we did all the adjustments he need to do
for age sex but it's some buddha child
index or comorbidity and for the
diagnostic group at drg so about as good
as you can do for observational data
and again let's look at what the high
level data showed so a small difference
in death rates favoring weekends so
weekends are worse and yet so you can
see it's about 2.1 percent versus 1.8
and these are important differences now
because we're dealing with millions of
patients so these are lots of people in
these very small numbers here
interestingly we looked at dr g's only
16 accounted for we had a weekend effect
but they were the big one so nearly
40-percent of death so again what is
going on here are the 16 dr g's we
struggle to find a pattern here any any
patterns occur to you when you look at
this a bit of a mixture isn't it's quite
quite a mess your cancers you've got
some cardiac events and pulmonary events
the answer is not much there's not much
you can say based on disease group and
again I have to say the team doing this
it's probably spent nine months looking
at the data again looking at
associations again getting very lost
everything they looked at you know
didn't seem to make a difference so
again don't the one thing I don't say on
there is any kind of infections correct
so that's the one thing that you know
must be intensity of service requirement
that's one hypothesis so for infections
you put them on the antibiotics you're
pretty good at giving those but for
these other things the complications
that can occur the sort of need to
monitor might be much more intense yeah
it's possible so so we'll see how that
unfolds and see whether you're right
okay so so again I said let's let's
start from first principles let's
imagine that we have these two competing
hypotheses one is poor quality of care
somehow we're doing a bad job on the
weekend the other one is higher acuity
on admission what would the temporal
signature look like if you compared one
to the other and what should we find in
the data
so the first pattern would be look if if
people are being admitted with higher
acuity illness then then they're being
exposed to care as it is and the
difference between the two populations
should therefore be the same irrelevant
a weekend there should be no weekend
affect another legit things shouldn't
get better during the weekday if these
people are just sick of people they're
always going to be sicker does that make
sense yeah if it's weekend effect due to
poor care then you can see something
like this so this is that this is excess
mortality right so people would get
admitted you'd accept expect to see a
some sort of peak in mortality due to
the pork hair on the weekend but then
over time as they get re exposed to good
care on the weekday then then you should
see that excess mortality disappearance
you should see that so read these are
the two these are the two competing
temporal signatures you'd expect to see
in the data if it was one or the other
and that allowed us to to create really
four separate hypotheses about what what
the time signature should show so the
first hair should if there was no
weekend effect should see nothing h1 is
if it's pure weekend effect you're going
to see just that peak which reduces to
zero sometimes during the week if these
are sick folks they're going to be sick
you know at least in short run all the
time or you might have both things
happening so you might have that next
picture what did we see we saw both so
there was only one pure weekend effect
which was quality of care and these are
the acute cardiovascular events yeah in
fact that cetera and these folks had a
very clear pattern of increased
mortality on the weekend which
disappeared very quickly once they got
Riggs posed to care trima they're all
dead I don't know then then although all
the respiratory events showed the same
washout but washed out over a longer
period everything else all the cancers
for example show this is really
statistically a straight line and these
are these are higher acuity patients
presenting on Friday evening or Saturday
presumably because
they're in primary care during the week
and the GPA said look it's Friday you're
not doing well I need to admit you you
know this is really probably poor
planning if you think about it and a
little bit of mixed effect here but so
you can really see the bulk of what's
going on actually is is higher acuity
for for interesting reasons but at least
one group you know the respiratory isn't
and the cardiovascular events really
seem to suggest something about quality
of care so that's really interesting
because that says there's no simple
answer to this complex problem there's
different things happening for different
groups of patients I think that's just
what I said so we'll move on okay this
picture is to remind you that sometimes
you need to take the thing that's
familiar and think about it differently
and so we're very pleased with ourselves
when we we did this work you know it got
a good attention when we published it
and you know we started to think about
well what do we see in the data I mean
if you do your standard analyses this is
what you see can we bring different eyes
to the data and maybe find something
else that's going on and so with all
what we're doing we're looking at
temporal signatures here where is the
body of knowledge for for this and the
body knowledge comes from biomedical
signal processing patient monitoring or
all all of that I've talked about is
standard signal processing over time and
can we bring those methods and those
those ideas over to what we're currently
looking at really is epidemiological or
statistical challenge and you know and
we make any mistakes and people know
what a liasing is aliasing alias and
effects so you should you should so this
is a very simple problem in temporal
analysis so imagine i've got a some time
varying pattern the the the curve i
recover depends on how frequently i
sample right so and the Nyquist rate
says you've got a sample
as fast as the frequency of the signal
so the aliases are the other patterns I
recover when I'm sampling below double
the frequency the Nyquist rate and so if
you sample too low you're actually
getting the wrong pattern so when we
start upping this worth or what might
the appropriate sample rate be because
what I've shown you is this I've shown
you the weekend effect which shows that
you know mortality rate speak on
Saturday and Sunday and that's that's
what the literature shows but what
happens if it would a sample more
quickly what would we see thought
you're not a trick question you see this
so there's not a weekend effect there's
a daily effect there's a Sevenfold
difference in mortality rates depending
on time of admission which makes sense
because you know your planned admissions
are happening in the morning and folks
who are coming in evening I've got to
have different issues there's a
difference in peak and duration which is
why you see that weekend effect but we
don't have a problem on weekends we have
a problem right through the week and you
know we need to be thinking about
service of care in a very different way
probably so this is really interesting
so the next step was so okay what can we
do with that information so as I said
one of our interest is in building
predictive models cuz it yeah so so what
what is the interval of sampling because
presume it seems to me that the lower
graph if you sort of tallied up the
24-hour time areas shouldn't give you
the upper thing missing something that
they should they do they do that it's
just one thing is to look at how fat how
fat these humps are so if you look at
area under the curve think of it that
way yeah so I think our sampling was if
four times a day yeah yeah maybe you're
going to get to this but one thing this
immediately makes me think is who cares
about planned admissions you know the if
you just can categorize them by plant
admissions irrespective of our the Dave
admission that the rate of mortality the
risk of mortality boots solo if you
exclude all those what kind of patterns
you see you still see a sort of
nighttime admission pattern or does it
really flatten out a lot more oh yeah so
we haven't done that good question but I
think at this point it's as though this
is his current work the question is will
now that we know this what should we
were looking at and and the use that
we've put it to is to to build a
predictive model so basically to say
look we could predict your risk of death
for example based on standard statistics
and those models you know have have sort
of our OCS about point eight something
like
let's now calculate your risk of death
based on time of admission let's let's
see what that does and when you just add
in that temporal value that then the the
model's start moving up to the point 95
so they're very they're much more
powerful model so so this sort of does
what you suggest in oil said look based
on knowing who you are and when you
arrived I know a lot more about what
your risks are so in a sense that's
exactly what we did do and I think and
that came out just about nine months ago
so this really says that those temples
you can just carry really important data
about you and your risks and you should
do something based on on that much more
personalized model so it's still early
days it's kind of fun we're still
looking at very high level
administrative data so go can you go
back is it back button you go previous
slide I actually realized why as you
were switching a slide your I was I
didn't look at the the y-axis I I
assumed that the baseline was something
really low but so you know now it makes
much more sense that the data adds up
under the curve but that's a potentially
misleading slide or potentially
misleading graph oh but it's exactly the
same time yeah so do you think that this
represents a variation in care or
variation in patients what this this is
the same data set so so the answer is it
represents both and depends on what you
want to do with the data so if you're
Richard it it still shows for example
that weekends are these are the worst
bits for sure just look at the area
under the curve so if you're going to
focus you should focus on that so the
thing that we need to do now for example
is to say what was going with the CVS
events why were these folks doing so
badly and our data set involved both
rural and urban hospitals if you're in
the city you're going to get your stint
in your
within an hour or so anyway on the
weekend their centers of excellence so
that's not going to be an issue but if
you're if you're a rural you're not and
so our guess is that really what we're
seeing is probably not an effective of
major major centers of excellence but
probably poor delays in care you know
we've gotten a lot of trouble when
published this paper from our state
because you said you know you're you're
representing our our state is delivering
really bad care some people still don't
talk to me in the department of health
and our message was not that this was
bad care but this was probably the
result of delay in access to care and
the message of the research is not don't
go to hospital on weekends at all but
getting there as early as you can but
that's the way you should see the data
but you can imagine how the media
portrayed the data set so you're going
to or you're in the process of
stratifying this out breaking it out by
you know rural and urban and larger yes
exacto you know medical condition like
you did with the with the other stuff
yeah yeah I'm innocent stay I wonder how
much of this represents you know people
getting admitted would they you know
that when they didn't want to you know
it's like you know who wants to be a my
little the hospital at seven p.m. on a
friday night right unless you know it's
almost like self-selecting yeah but so
for example when you compare injuries
you know something turns up it that
that's not driven by your choice but
there's no excess mortality on weekend
for for trauma you know your risks are
the same weekday weeknight so so that's
service the ed service and presumably
the emergency surgical surgical services
are set up to handle you in the same way
so so it's not it's not the people
turning up with with you no broken bones
from from football or something okay
I think that's it thank you thank you
for your talk I hope you don't mind if I
ask a techie questions go does the fact
if you're using EHR Brand X Y or Z make
it easier or harder to pull this level
of granular data so what's interesting
about these data sets is that they are
administrative report data so this is
the stuff that most hospitals would
report anyway centrally so the data
we're looking at now is that that more
granular EHR data for that for the sort
of the predictive models and the
forecasting or the green button
technology but what you're seeing here
is just run-of-the-mill state report
data nothing special at all for the labs
the lab results that we we were lucky
that we had a homegrown EHR and that
they were willing to put timestamps into
the system so when I spoke to goodys
shift over at partners who wanted to
repeat the study he was unable to
because they wouldn't put the time stamp
in on on the read so very frustrating
for him so I think it's not so much
access to the data but it's be able to
instrument the data set so remember what
we're doing here is we're very
interested in the behavior of the users
over the aggregate and I think that
that's the thing that people will
struggle with which is being able to
convince either the vendors or your
local groups to to put in those
little-little logs that you want
okay I was just going to actually ties
back to your comment in the beginning
about Chris Longhurst green button which
actually gets its name from the blue
button yeah is the VA blue button that
you can as a patient you can download
but this actually makes me think about
the green button because even though I'm
you know fascinated by the opportunity
to learn from data that's sitting there
in the system I think you're sort of
drilling down into the details of your
data show problems with that approach
you know looking at you know data that's
that's sitting in your system because
that you know the sampling interval for
example are you doing anything else with
a green button and and do you have any
concerns about you know you may find
something that that is really due to a
confounder or something like that so
we're not worried about confounding
because we sort of understand how to
handle that so the model really is that
you need to but you need to pick a match
cohort of patients that are significant
statistically so you Pia you've got
diabetes heart disease and a bunion I've
got to make a choice about how close the
patients are to you to create that
artificial cohort and so what we're
working on is is on how you would select
the boundary and we see basically the
boundary is a slider so for some
patients you're going to have so many so
many similar patients that it's going to
be significant statistically it's going
to be very powerful I can find people
very close to you but for others the
rare disease is that slider to get a
cohort that matches will start to
incorporate all sorts of odds and sods
and so probably what what we're thinking
is that we need to give you a sense of
the quality of the match before you move
forward and make a decision and so it's
not simply hit the button here a hundred
people it's well actually going to find
twenty people that were useful and
they're not that significant really
because what you've got is really quite
unusual so so that's I think it's rather
than saying it's a problem it's
something we need to we need to expose
and make you realize you can always use
that the daughter in that way you know
this work really makes me think about a
couple I mean besides data and
information quality in general which has
been really interesting for us in terms
of trying to start to think about that
operationalize for his research is you
know what can the underlying data it's
time the person the role the person
who's ordering or reviewing the data the
organizational structures in which they
practice what can that tell you about
whether this is due to something about
the patient or something about the
system of care and then how can I be
used to inform actual quality
improvement right because you know the
work here you sort of heard people
saying well I don't know what's you know
what's the real cause of this as you
progress with this what are your next
thoughts about what kind of studies you
designed to start to look more deeply at
what's due to the system and which parts
of the system versus the underlying it
look I think the high level response is
the one that I've already given which is
that I think unguided analysis of the
data is a waste of time you look at a
million data data data data variables
and you're going to find correlations
you really have to be driven by
questions and you have to be driven by
questions driven by your service and
your insights and intuition so you know
have it having a bunch of data
scientists who don't understand the
workflows doesn't really bring you much
so you really need this is really a
partnership of people who actually have
deep knowledge about service and and and
and what the problems are as well as the
people who have those really important
skills around the analysis and so we got
stuck a lot and things unfolded only
when went back to first principles and
said what do you think is really going
on here and and surprisingly quickly we
found things
I've been thinking about your slider II
showed all the conditions that had
higher mortality on the weekend and a
question that came to mind is I'm
wondering if there's anything that has
to do with continuity of a care provider
and weekend coverage where maybe some of
those conditions you know you you have a
care provider that has longitude no
knowledge of you whereas in trauma you
don't tend to have that relationship so
so it's hard to answer with the data set
we've got the we had a cancer specialist
on our team for the data because of the
large proportion of cancer patients and
he said look the most obvious workflow
issue for me is is actually that there
is a late late hand off of the patient
to the hospital on on the weekend and
really what should have happened is
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday the patient's
deteriorating there should have come in
in a planned way not as an emergency I
mean with with the cancer patient issue
you shouldn't be you know friday evening
saturday morning depositing lots lots of
people in who just all of a sudden not
doing very well that's that a failure of
handover and a failure of planning i
think so that's as close as we've got to
answering that question but i think
you're absolutely right it's got to do
with this you know understanding what
the needs are of the patient yes there
any plans or discussion about you know
using this for more like hypothesis
testing than hypothesis discovery
because now that you've got a way of
characterizing and measuring something
you know you sort of follows up with
david's question about you know how to
use this to improve care and then you
could follow up with the measurements to
see if it actually improved played it
did reduce the variation these timings
and that kind of stuff and then how what
are your thoughts about how you'd
actually set something like that up i
think i think it gives you the tools
then to do that I mean this is still
fairly recent for us what's worrying is
that some hospitals are very changed
practice based on our results so you
know a couple of hospitals in another
state back home said well we've we've
gone 24 7 on you know with we've got
better coverage which is fantastic but
natural but but unplanned and unstudied
so it's a wasted opportunity so which
was what happens with all quality
improvement in
and it's just these are wasted
opportunities ah but you know but as a
scientist I'm not happy i'm not happy
I've got to do hypothesis testing it's
going to be a prospective yeah so well
that really underpins the sort of
suggestions we've made around what one
should do and so it it makes no sense to
me that that fifty percent of these
tests that i looked up just just get
done on their discharge that is a
massive failure of somebody telling
somebody an important piece of
information and when you do the
qualitative work that we've done it's
it's it's often just a failure to know
that the patients are going home you
know so that who's made the decision to
go home is it planned or unplanned and
why haven't you told you know the people
in your team that they're going home why
is this battery of tests being ordered
the other thing that the lab say is that
they're very bad at communicating how
long it will take for a result to come
back this sort of magical thinking i'll
put the test in it'll be back today but
you know some tests get bashed up and
only get done once a week for example
you may not see a result for some some
tests for a week or more so is that
going to change your care in the in the
next two days maybe not so i think
underpinning those issues are our
communication solutions for sure
along the same lines do you find that
discharge order sets may be partially to
blame that we're just ordering batches
of stuff and conversely in the state's
ordering single tests is the payers like
that better than ordering test panels
like em hell does that have the opposite
effect of making them more likely more
likely to a fire but we don't know so
one of the things I'm interested in is
is what i would call inertia in other
words the the ability of people to
respond to different signals about
what's going on and and the fan of able
to respond to important signals so the
next piece on that which we shall we're
writing up now so don't go do this it is
looking at the signal in the lab test
result in terms of whether it's normal
or abnormal and and does that affect to
follow up right so you know my intuition
is if I'm ordering a test for a patient
who's sick as a physician I'm probably
going to be wanting to to get that
result you know you're unwell I'm
ordering for a reason so therefore I'll
be following up more likely then if the
patient's results come back of normal it
turns out that that there's no
difference in behavior depending on
abnormality at all in other words we
think it's workflow driven but basically
that there is there are so much work to
be done on the shop floor in the
hospital that people's capacity to
respond signals is so low that it's not
changing for lot behavior so so I still
really think that a lot of what we're
seeing is just driven by the way the
machine is built and I don't think it's
a it's a cognition issue i don't think
it's um an issue about training
necessarily i think they're prompts and
and nudges you can provide to get people
to do things but i think this this is a
starling law this is really this is how
tests get followed up in this hospital
because you built the hospital to
produce this curve so if you reproduce
that here i guess you're going to get
the same shape curve but i think it'll
be it'll have different value
this is my guess so so you know the
thing with abnormal values that's so
tricky and this may relate to your next
tomorrow's activities that you're
engaged on is that most abnormal values
are meaningless they have no meaning
because it really depends on the patient
like if you take creatinine which is one
of the most commonly ordered labs it
really is what what is their crappening
usually and is this different in some
way is it better as it worse and so for
every patient for some sets of lab the
or note of normal rules are set very
poorly they're technically abnormal but
they're not meaningfully abnormal and
for some labs it's very patient
dependent where I expected abnormal lab
it's how abnormal it is that really
matters not to say that you know not
reviewing it is is acceptable in either
of those cases it's just if you do set
thresholds or sort of try and ask
specific questions looking for that
probably your models would be much
better you know is this creatinine that
was unreviewed worse or better than the
previous one even though it's abnormal
you're right and and you could
absolutely do that but don't forget one
down lining reasons we study this is
because a nun followed up test is an
economic cost so so why did you order
the damn thing and even if these are all
you know mm-hmm information theory
adding no information to it to the pool
at all then you shouldn't have ordered
the necessarily so I think either way
it's still problematic but your own
difference between commonly ordered
tests and rare tests in terms of you
know follow up with the with the results
we didn't see that we didn't see that we
I think the there were there was only
potassium's were different and I think
they'll probably the only ones but and I
said even there the workflow that
they're one of the few tests where the
lab workflow is very different where
they was put a phone call through to the
ordering position anyway so the rest was
all through through the CPOE system
my pleasure thank you